(upbeat music)
- First of all, this looks awesome.
- You expect this to look
kinda hard, don't you?
It's not, it's soft. It's soft.
- There's stuff in the middle.
- That red bean?
It's like sticky.
- Salty, it's sweet,
it's crunchy, it's chewy.
- It's a very interactive
dessert, which I like.
You get to pick it up and
play with it, and like
squish it, and like pull it apart.
It's fun.
(upbeat music)
- Dan tut.
- Oh.
- That bite is really,
interesting and fun and new.
- Very edgy.
- Like you really taste the egg.
It doesn't taste like creamy, milky sugar.
- It's like a mini pie, a mini egg pie.
(upbeat music)
- It kinda looks like a soup.
Like a dessert soup.
- That's weird.
I'm not used to having soup for dessert.
- This is so good.
- It just has an interesting texture.
It's like tea with stuff at the bottom.
(upbeat music)
- Here's how I judge things.
Taste, adorableness, that's the end.
- D'aww, he's very jello-ey.
- It taste's like condensed
milk and mango mixed together.
- The texture is right in the middle
between pudding and jello.
- These desserts have an element
of fun, I'm not gonna lie.
It's like it taste's good, but
then it's also a lot of fun.
(upbeat music)
- I see little balls everywhere.
- It's like a little party in your mouth.
- It smells bomb.
- It's really good with the mango.
Cause the mango is nice and tart,
and like the coconut cream is just like,
like a little sweet but mostly neutral,
so it like balances it
all out really well.
- This is like the freshest
dessert of all time.
This is the best.
- My favorite is the sesame ball, easily.
- The black sesame soup was
actually really fun, and different.
- I really like the dan tut.
And I said it right.
Maybe.
- Sai Mai Lo, is that right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
Yep, that was the best one.
That was the best one by far.
- The sesame balls are kinda magical.
Like they're kind of
like made out of magic,
I think those balls are.
- Two thumbs up for Hong Kong desserts.
(upbeat music)